North Korea's leader Kim Jong-un has met
Russia's defense minister and a
high-ranking Chinese delegation in
Pyongyang the Kim's first known The
prominent foreign visitors since the
beginning of the covid-19 pandemic three
years ago
Korea's defense minister says Russia and
Pyongyang are united in countering what
they called gangster-like U.S hegemony
both Russian and Chinese delegations are
visiting North Korea as part of the 70th
anniversary of the Korean War armistice
or ceremonies are also being held in
South Korea on the occasion let's now go
live to Florence Lewis she's in Busan
for us now Florence what more do we know
about this North Korea visit
well this visit by the the Chinese and
Russian delegation in a way it is also
intended for a North Korean domestic
audience it is Kim Jong-un leader of
North Korea's way of saying to his
people look how important this country
our country is we have foreign
delegation visiting but it's also it's
meant to send a message to the
International Community now the Chinese
delegation was led by a Polish Bureau
member a mid-ranking official but North
Korean State Media made it a point to
say that he came bearing a letter from
Chinese Premier from Chinese president
Xi Jinping now Russia sent a much more
senior official defense minister Sergey
shoigu and he is the first Russian
defense minister to visit North Korea
since the fall of the Soviet Union now
like his Chinese
um like the Chinese delegation he also
came with a letter from President
Vladimir Putin addressed to Kim
highlighting the two leaders close
relationship but he also attended a
defense exhibition in young where on
display was banned ballistic missiles
amongst other weapons and analysts say
this is significant because it could
suggest Russia's acceptance of North
Korea's nuclear program now the
relationship between Russia and North
Korea seems to be mutually beneficial if
you will remember U.S officials have
accused Russia of buying weapons from
North Korea North Korea and Russia deny
that but if it were true this would also
give an explanation as to why Russia
values its relationship with North Korea
and Florence the north and south are
marking the occasion very differently
aren't they
very very differently in the South you
have Veterans of the Korean War from the
countries that took part in the Korean
War they've been invited by the South
Korean government to take part in
commemorative events and on Thursday
that started with a visit to the UN
Cemetery to honor soldiers who died
during that war some of whom are buried
in the cemetery here in Busan and later
the South Korean president will attend a
ceremony with these veterans but in the
north however this is being marked in a
much more celebratory manner there was
what North Korean State media described
a as a grand performance with singers
dancers school children performing for
the North Korean leader as well as the
visiting Russian and Chinese delegation
now North Korea
describes this day as a Day of Victory
of for the grand liberation of North
Korea
now it's not just how this day is being
marked that sets these two countries
apart it's also the people attending in
North Korea you have the Chinese and the
Russian Who provided support for North
Korea during the war but who are also
remain close supporters of North Korea
to this day and in the South you have
the countries that supported the U.S led
U.N command that provided International
troops as well as medical personnel
during the Korean War and in a way this
highlights not just the differences
between North Korea and South Korea but
also the differences
that divide the country at present you
have on one side the U.S and its allies
and on the other you have Russia and
China and it's more authoritarian States
okay we'll leave it there Florence Louis
thank you very much indeed